everyone and welcome to today's live
webinar cancer on a chip the micro
fluidic 2d and 3d cell culture system
for studying cellular microenvironments
presented by dr. Vivek comments I'm
Christie jewel of laboratory moderating
this session today's educational web
seminar is presented by laborat and
brought to you by get Co at Thermo
Fisher Scientific now let's get started
today's event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
in the ask a question box and click send
we will answer as many questions as we
appoint boil at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation use that ask
a question box and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of your presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I now present you today's
speaker dr. Vivek comments postdoctoral
associate Florida International
University for a complete biography on
our speaker please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen
dr. comment you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the introduction good
morning my name is dr. Vivek common
firstly I like to thank Chipko and Tom
official scientific or giving me this
platform to say my work I would also
like to thank Jesse for giving this
opportunity to talk about micro fluidic
2d and 3d cell culture systems for
cancer research started I would like to
share some background information and
other typical insights about my
education workplace and academic career
I was born in City awfully also in an
Oxford of the eh located on the western
Indian state of Maharashtra the speeds
blessed with vibrant rich coat has also
highest number of research organizations
in India I did my graduation and
post-graduation biotechnology from
karate college and carried my capital
work at a Virgo Research Institute and
the Sigma BLT in 2000 meeting after
which I immediately joined the group of
dr. Shekhar burns early at Florida
International University in the
Department of Electrical Engineering
so to begin with here are the cancer
statistics obtained by World Health
Organization which shows the valence of
cancer throughout the globe in the image
it can be seen that premature mortality
rates are significantly higher and is
the number one leading cause of death in
48 countries which are indicated by the
blue colour is the second leading cause
of death in countries marked with light
blue color and countries with fourth and
fifth leading cause of death are marked
in orange and red color it is expected
that until 2020
there will be one eighteen point eight
eighteen point 1 million new cases with
nine point six million deaths due to
cancer and therefore cancer research is
on the major priorities in developed and
developing nations so currently the
major challenges faced are early
detection cancer prediction new tox
screening and post cancer treatment so
to address this challenge the first
experimental step starts on carrying out
in vitro cell culture assays but there
is a need to develop better models to
study cancer as we all know that the
magnitude of radiation which we receive
during performing in vitro to in vivo
transitions so we need better systems
because to study cellular functions and
behaviors in dynamic condition which
mimics in vivo scenarios understand for
micro environment is realistic way and
study various core and multi culture
systems which would eventually bridge
the gap between in vitro and in vivo
system generating realistic data in
pliny primary stages of investigation so
let us see how dynamics whether micro
environment works dynamic system is
combination of biochemical physical and
chemical factors which constitutes cells
micro environment as seen in the
schematic cell experiences blood flow
shear stress pressure draw stretching
interaction with physical barriers and
collectively imparting physical forces
on the cells further there is
concentration gradients exchange of
gases there are chemical signaling
molecules and extra cellular cellular
molecules which constitute the
biochemical factors and lastly
physicochemical factors such as
temperature pH collectively interact and
affect the cells and yet in such a
dynamic system cells are able to
replicate and perform its designated
function
but in traditional dish phase or you
know not conventional assays
functions such as sensing replication
exchange of materials might be altered
as cells do not experience a dynamic
environment it is known that cell
exchange morphologies when cells I mean
I'm sorry
it is known that cell changes
morphologies when exposed to substrate
deformation but cells in culture player
do not experience these forces and
eventually lose these properties
therefore studying dynamic system for
studying cellular microenvironment
without compromising natural properties
and behavior of the cells is crucial so
how can we study some dynamic systems
and one of the one of the answers is by
products so what is micro fluidics micro
fluidics is study and manipulation of
small volumes of fluid in channels and
chamber when dimensions of tens of micro
liters microfluidic cell culture
attempts to develop devices and
techniques for culturing maintaining
analyzing and experimenting cells in
micro scale volume now using this
microfluidic technique we can actually
we can actually make devices to carry
out 2d and 3d cell culture systems in
the following image shows a microfluidic
chip comprising of inlets for media a
culture chamber in which cells can be
grown and outfit for removal of span
media so such chips can be used to
culture cancer cells for assessing
various different cellular activities so
now let us see what are the differences
between in vitro culture and
microfluidic cell culture system in in
vitro system the cell substrate is
transparent stiff and as low gas
permeability while Microsystems the
substrate is soft and is flexible and
also has high gas permeability in
multiple systems cells can be handle and
cultured ranging from single mm cell
which is actually not possible in a
plate base as a conventional cultures is
carried out in flask dish and plates
which requires larger volume as compared
to metaphysic devices which can work
with volumes as less as 60 nano liters
also nutrient in traditional culture and
in great excess and media needs change
after every 48 hours why in my trading
system media turnover is fast
and some reports indicate more glucose
consumption one peculiar thing about
microfluidic cell culture is the
pollination rate and in conventional
assays the politicians the rate is
typically between 18 to 24 hours but in
magnetic system there have been reports
where it has been shown less as well as
faster politician rates of the cells so
how do we culture cells in microfluidics
systems considering cells in magnetic
devices require a strong understanding
of certain fundamental principles
spanning disciplines such as physics
chemistry biology and engineering so
it's more of an interdisciplinary kind
of study and there are certain criterias
which need to be follow both see the
developed system should closely mimic
conditions that exist in vivo and the
person handling should have good command
on cell culture techniques to translate
methods from macro to a microscope I
mean to micro to macro scale and this is
usually the most challenging part also
another criteria is person should have a
strong background in designing and micro
fabrication techniques so let us see
what are the steps involved in
establishing a successful microfluidic
culture so the first step obviously is
the fabrication of the device this is
typically carried out by techniques such
as photolithography and soft lithography
after which you have to select the type
of cell which you are going to
investigate so it can be cancerous non
cancerous cells and based on their
property such as adherent or not other
end we might need to fabricate a
different or leave this in a
microfluidic chain then we need to
perfuse media into the chip which is
usually done using syringe pump or
peristaltic pumps the chips are then
monitored using microscopic technique we
usually use light cell microscopy in our
lab and at last the spend media is
collected which contains all the extra
cellular components and dead cells so
let us see the first step which is the
fabrication process in details so
fabrication process is divided into two
parts one is calligraphy and another
soft lithography so as the name suggests
photolithography is a technique which
uses which is used to etch surface using
light and this is usually a UV source
basically in little in photo lithography
we have a mask which is nothing but a
stencil on this the design of the
metaphysic chip is edged on a silicon
substrate substrate which is called a
wafer a layer of photoresist is coated
up we in our lab we use su-8 for this
after which the mask is aligned on the
substrate and UV is exposed once exposed
for a definite time the UV light passes
through the stencil of the mask and
erodes the photoresist at the point
creating design on the mask onto the
substrate after etching the final baking
and development is carried out to obtain
the substrate with the design for the
PDMS which is a known polymer it's
called poly dimethyl siloxane is added
to the substrate and allowed to cure
once PDMS solidifies it is it is peeled
off and the replicated design is and the
design gets replicated on PDMS in case
of soft lithography the move is first
prepared and then PDMS is just added
into the mold and cured PDMS is a
room-temperature vulcanized rubber that
solidifies and mixed with curing agent
and this process can be accelerated by
applying heat so of curing the PDMS is
the old heel and the electric design
pattern on the PDMS further this is the
process of photolithography
so as I explained earlier in the first
step the silicon wafer is removed from
the cleanroom
it is kept on the spin coater in the
third step the photoresist such as su a
polymer is added and it spin a desired
rpm to achieve a specific thickness and
then it is pre-baked of the disc the
mask is selected F six and seven is
aligning of the mask using a mask
aligner in step eight UV is exposed and
finally in step 10 the mask
both surfaces wash finally we have the
desired desired geometry on the wafer
now this acts as a mold and PDMS is
added on the wafer which is allowed to
cure and the microfluidic chip
disappeared so in the last image you can
see the design of the metallic chips and
the channel in case of soft lithography
the process is quite simple and I would
like to share one step protocol which we
use in a lab design circular micro micro
channels and chambers oh the protocol
goes that the protocol describes of
using other OHS powder is readily
available which you can mix with water
and allow it to boil we then cut the tip
of syringe desperate this averroes
powder and allow it to cool once folded
the black push the girls out from the
syringe to get cylindrical Averroes
shape cut the agarose into desire height
and pass copper wire through the upper
of cylinder then we place this entire
set up into a box and you just add PDMS
into it we keep the entire setup at 70
degrees for three hours which is the
curing process and later once PDMS is
solidified it just removes the chip and
boiled in water the agarose will melt
off and you can simply pull off the wire
having circular channels and chambers
and this can be used to culture chips
it's called yourself any so there are
certain parameters which means to
optimize for successful cell culture and
these parameters are first is the flow
rate so flow rate can can be set using
syringe pump or peristaltic pumps
usually flow rates can be set to mimic
actual flow condition in blood vessels
and capillaries which range from one to
two thousand micro liters per minute
second is the temperature and co2
control cells require physiological
temperature and co2 control therefore
you can use a PID controller or with
heating plate coupled with co2
controller or there is also an automated
on stage incubator with co2 systems
which are available which can be mounted
on microscope to perform lights and
imaging and lastly we also need to
monitor the cells for which you can use
inverted microscope or even less
microscope
so using these techniques we attempted
to culture cells in a 2d platformer in
the first image you can see the methyl
credit chip which was fabricated using
photolithography the chip consists of
inlets and outlets which are
interconnected to small chambers which
are 100 micron in height and 3 mm in
diameter media containing DME m and F
well supplemented with 10% FBS was used
for the experiments and the selected MDM
b23 one sells for our study after the
chip was abdicated the chip was coated
with poly lysine has 5 limiting to allow
cells to adhere then MDM b23 one sells
for inoculated in the channel and
allowed to inhibit
intubate for two to four hours this is
crucial since cells need some time to
substrate and we cannot immediately
start the flow rate after 2 to 4 hours
challenge with the media is placed in
the pump and at a set add at a desired
flow rate and connect it to the chip we
need to take care not to not to set the
flow rate too high because that would
end up leading formation of bubbles
which is a major challenge in
microfluidic 2d and 3d cell culture
systems further we increment the system
at 37 degrees Celsius at 5% co2
we monitored the sense by recording
time-lapse imaging of the cells up every
three minutes for 12 hours at different
flow rates and I have a sample video
which shows the migration of the cells
the flow rate was 3 mic liters per
minute and comma data we came to a
conclusion that flow rate has negligible
effect on cell migration in this
timeless it is seen that cells are
pulling in flow condition but are not
affected by curate rather we can also
see some cells which are migrating in
the opposite direction of the flow also
it was noted that cell proliferation was
much slower although these findings are
still under investigation but our
initial proof of concept further we also
found that cells to tend to adhere to
the side walls of the microfluidic chip
as compared to the central region this
is probably due to low pressure at the
side walls as compared to the central
region and also due to high surface
roughness at the edges which provide
better contact points for the cell
another recent investigation which we
are working on is testing of different
truck loaded nanoparticles on cancer
cells in our finding post 6 our
treatment cellular death and cell
shrinking was observed but strikingly
after 12 hours of pee to observe some
cells trying to re-establish and poly
filling which might be useful to explore
drug resistance and uneven diffusion of
prevent continuous flow of this might
help develop better drug molecules to
treat cancer although these studies look
simpler there are several challenges
which are encountered in microfluidic
system the major been controlling the
evaporation rate and generation of
bubbles so in the image sea you can see
that you can usually end up having these
bubbles in the microfluidic chips which
is a major challenge but overall if
these problems are taken care it's easy
to establish a duty or a 3d cell culture
system now when we come to 3d
environment everything changes so 3d
tumor models are most ideal to study
cancer
abnormal growth of cells lead to tumor
formation and you know tumors comprises
of several cells in clusters and this
makes it challenging to love it so I
think the schematic tumors an
experienced non-uniform exposure to
nutrients and oxygen there is different
qualification gradient along with
altered cell signaling also exposure to
drug is limited because most of the
cells are on the surface and this and
the cells at the core of the tumor do
not get exposed to the drug molecules
but but technically this is what is in
legal condition right so how do we
develop tumor models in continuous flow
system so our first step of study was to
investigate different scaffolds which
would serve as a 3d architecture for the
cells to grow so we selected gelatin
cellulose PDMS and one novel scaffold
which is a carbon-based scaffold for a
study the study is still under
investigation but I would like to share
some very primary study results so the
average pore size of the scaffold range
from 5 to 50 micron which depends on the
synthesis protocol and how we make the
different scaffolds I have incorporated
an image of the scaffolds and primary
studies we did using a 6-well plate
assay where we carried out different
biocompatibility studies and also MPI
say so initially we tested the
biocompatibility and it is found that
these scaffolds operative biocompatible
like we just stick to Studies on NIH and
MD MD to 3-1 further this gap volts or
was incorporated into microscopic chip
which was designed in such a way which
will hold the scaffolds in the cell
culture chamber so the chip comprises of
Inlet and outlet with a single large
chamber and this chamber was somewhere
around 40 mm by 10 mm in this the
scaffolds was place prior to bonding
with the glass slides then the medium
Inlet was connected and using this
protocol described earlier we were able
to cut the cells on these scaffolds in
the following image
can see that we have this experimental
setup we're in connect the area to the
check but this entire setup is usually
on an on-stage incubator
under the microscope or also you can
place this entire setup in in a in a co2
incubator
of problems which we were facing during
our studies was that when he stained the
scaffolds we usually end up with died of
which remains back into scaffold and it
is very difficult to image them so as
you can see we when we tried using
gelatin and PDMS carefully were able to
see cells growing in voids of the
scaffolds and establish small tumor like
structures nevertheless we were able to
establish the these cells in the
scaffolds are we also observed similar
results when we used PDMS scaffolds and
also cellular scaffolds as you can see
that we have these tumors to temper
spirits which are growing on this
cellulose scaffolds after three days of
incubation
lastly the the scaffold which we are
right now we have which we are working
on is the birthday scaffold and in the
first image you can see that you know it
has an interval network of these fibers
along and we track we tried growing
cells in these fibers and we were pretty
successful in growing sets up to 14 days
as you can see in the image of P we
ended up with tumor mass of cells
ranging from 100 to 200 microns in
diameter at present we are working to
characterize the scaffold and tumor
bodies and I have not included that data
in the presentation
so to summarize microfluidic cell
culture microchip was successfully
fabricated using photolithography a
simpler method for fabricating was
exploding in soft lithography we did not
saw any influence of flow rate on
migration sensed prefer to grow in the
region of low pressure along the side
walls of the chip in the 2d microfluidic
chip and 3d cell culture was established
in continuous flow by incorporating
different biocompatible scaffold lastly
we were successfully able to culture
cells up to 14 days which eventually
turned out to be a tumor which
eventually turned out to be
of scalpel human tumor cells
lastly I would like to acknowledge my
mentors dr. Shekhar Byrne chali for
providing me the opportunity to work in
his lab dr. the ninja Buddhist and dr.
Kishore buck nickel for his excellent
mentoring and support during my PhD it
eventually made me independent
researcher my colleagues and friend dr.
Natalia and dr. L NARS for their
scientific inputs and help for this work
and lastly Isabella and Dennis who are
working with me on this project and we
are exploring new possibilities every
day thank you and you can reach me out
on these contact listed any questions
you
dr. Kamat thank you for your
presentation okay so let's get started
with our QA just a quick reminder to our
audience on how to submit questions just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen as a
reminder any questions that we are
unable to get to today dr. Kamat will be
answering them via email so don't worry
if we don't get to your question right
away okay let's see our first question
is why not use serum-free medium culture
conditions
hello yeah big the question
absolutely our Valerie is asking why not
use serum-free medium color condition
okay yeah so basically like when we
started doing the studies like I never
tested with serum in media because
usually the thing is when culturing
cells in these kind of microfluidic
devices I usually end up with less cell
viability if I start using media free of
serum
so usually media supplemented with 10%
FPS is the most ideal condition and in
that kind of a condition we usually get
cells poly correcting in a better way
rather than using the media free of
serum
thank you now we have a question coming
in from the University of Michigan what
is the size of organoid when you
finished 14 days scaffold culture yeah
so after 14 days of after 14 days of the
culture when we measured the size of the
scaffold when the measured when we
measure the size of the organized we
were able to get somewhere around 80 to
150 micron size ASCAP orgonite um so
that was it
thank you your next question when
performing cell migration studies what
was the seeding density of cells in the
chip and part of the flow rate how would
the flow rate optimize for the studies
um so then performing the migration
study we basically see the advantage to
four cells in the micropedic chip and to
optimize the flow rate of basically we
started from three microliters per
minute and went up till 100 microliters
per minute which is the which is similar
to the flow rate observed in arteries
and veins and so in that in that thing
we were able to see the cells migrating
in against the flow rate also and that
was the that was the condition how we
set up the experiment
now projects Martin do you have
experience with co-cultures of cells um
we haven't tried Co culturing cells yet
but soon I'll be working on co-culture
system with our astrocytes and noodle
cells we using the same PDMS or the
carbon-based a phone
we have another question coming in here
you mentioned the scaffold had an
approximate pore size of 50 um however
some of the steroids you observed were
100 um in diameter so this suggests that
the scaffold was flexible enough to
stretch allowing a larger spheroid so um
in the initial studies a microscopic
studies which I have observed although
the pore size of the is smaller usually
that sense tends to cling on these
scaffolds or these groups and usually we
see at some points that the scaffold is
flexible in case of PDMS we did observe
the scaffold to be quite flexible and
cells growing within the scaffolds and
then they are we also see some of the
cells growing outside the scaffold
making a larger steroid kind of a
structure
so yes the scaffolds are flexible but
that also depends on type of Piscopo so
we did not saw that in case of
carbon-based careful but in PDMS
scaffold we did see that the scaffold is
quite flexible and we usually get a
large square roots
thanks for that question Jeffrey and we
actually have another one from him we're
going to go on to this one did you
observe significant nonspecific cell
binding to the tubing interface to the
PDMS chip
that's a good question of Taliah so it
usually ends up that way we do see a lot
of cells which bind to the tubing but
not a significant amount of cells but
yes cells to tend to earlier to be
tubing as well as to the channels the
inlet channel specifically at the inlets
and the outlets so if two Tavares are up
estimate around 5 to 10 percent of cells
seed itself we usually end up into the
teens and into the inlets and outlets of
the chip
thank you doctor come on and here we
have another question have you
investigated the effect of different
culture media on the growth and
metabolism of cancer cells grown ex-vivo
ah no not really actually I have not
tested different type of media's yet
on the cancer cell but on in one of my
previous studies we do also change in
morphologies of any use different kind
of media in continuous blow cultures but
I haven't used I haven't done a complete
study using different type of media's
yet
okay and our next question coming in
here we have so many great questions
coming in as a reminder to our audience
those questions that dr. Claude is
unable to answer today due to time
constraints he will be answering them
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration all right
let's go on to our next question how do
you make a 3d structure in a
microfluidic device okay so basically
like we are basically making these
scaffolds
which are of three dimension and then
incorporating them in the microfluidic
device so there are several protocols
which in which the device itself the
scaffolds are and inside the device but
before binding it 2d to us we do
incorporate these scaffolds into the
microfluidic device so basically we are
not making the structures in the device
structures have made separately and then
incorporated in the device by bonding
with other plasma bonding it or the
other methods so in case of PDMS usually
we make these porous Kapil's and then we
incorporate it in these smaller devices
and then we carry out the cell culture
study so it's kind of easy in a way that
we can later on just open up these
devices and remove this scaffold so we
get out we get the entire structure
intact but with cells which are growing
on the scaffold so it's quite easy to
extract this scaffold from the devices
and that's how we work a
thanks mom now what are the chances of
contamination and other troubleshooting
oh yeah actually oh that's a good
question so you usually end up with the
the chances of contamination is it
depends on on the handling and also on
the conditions usually you won't get a
contamination unless you have properties
not properly sterilized the media of the
microchip and other other you know
devices and tubing and everything but
usually if the tubing's and the
connectors are not taken care of then we
usually end up with contamination and
also other troubles the major
troubleshooting is as I mentioned we
usually end up with bubbles which which
is at the major kind of issues when
using magnetic devices and also
sometimes evaporation there so if a flow
rate is too less we usually it evacuated
evaporates commedia or something like
that and then that's another challenge
so it takes a lot of time to optimize
these systems but once it is optimized
it's really you know it gives a real
good results
now let's go back to the topic of
scaffold now I have a few versions of
this question coming in was the scaffold
treated prior to the experiment so what
we usually do is we treat the scaffolds
with oli and icing for center Darren so
after the after the scaffolds have been
prepared we usually wash them in 70% IPA
and then two or three washes to CVS and
then try to keep the scaffold in
deionized water for at least four to six
hours and after that we treat it with
polyethylene percent or dirhams
now dr. Scott was any viability out they
performed and if not which are the
assays to characterize the tumor bodies
um so actually healing a bit by to study
the cells under the microscope
so basically other other bodies other
acids which can be performed could be a
light deck staining or you know ATP
generation si and also um one can go for
Chi sixty-seven based assays which are
at is it a politician marker in tumor
cell
so basically fluorescent based assays
can be carried out to study cell
viability and poly facial
thank you doctor come on now we have
time for one more question which drug
loaded nanoparticles were used in the
study and how is the study carried out
so this is this is one of one of the
studies which I've been playing in my
group and basically we are making
different nanoparticles which are
natural natural polymers using keiko-san
or alginate nanoparticles and what we do
is we synthesize these nanoparticles in
the range of 100 to 150 nanometers which
are encapsulated with the antigens drugs
such as
doxorubicin or black tea toxin and then
we try to study the effect of these nano
drugs on cancer cells in continuous
local culture so basically using these
nanoparticles to study how the cellular
uptake or how does the activity drug
activity and interaction with the cells
takes place in a continuous flow kind of
a culture
Thank You dr. klahn now you have a final
comment for an audience um so um yeah I
mean I this field is quite challenging
and interesting and it's we can do a lot
of studies using my critics felt like
the system traditionally it's possible
in your future to translate all the in
vitro studies to micro fluidic systems
it would be really create and would give
us a great depth of understanding in
studying these cellular microenvironment
and cellular interaction at a more
dynamic level rather than using the
traditional in vitro si so thank you
everyone I would like to once again
thank dr. Vivek come up first time today
and for his important contribution to
cell culture research I would also like
to thank lab roots and our sponsors
Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
now before we go I'd like to thank all
of you for joining us today and for your
great questions again questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this club cast can
be viewed on-demand laborat swill alert
you via email when it's available for
replay and we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event you will
now be redirected to the registration
page for our upcoming webinars on
choroid plexus epithelial cell 2d and
modified 3d cell culture models
presented by our next cell culture hero
dr. Elizabeth delery dr. delery will be
presenting live on July 31st at 9:00
a.m. Pacific time we hope to see you
there bye for now
and have a great day